do you know any people right now think
they're being loyal but what they
actually are are enablers to toxic
behavior when it comes to being a young
person you don't have like a great
family you don't have a lot of support
of people around you find your [__]
family are you kidding me that's why we
love friends so much you pick those
[__] I didn't pick my brother and
sister though I'm very lucky because I
love them both but I know a lot of
people that don't we pick our friends
and by the way [__] changes too I love
loyalty I'm still a Jets and Knicks fan
but if your friend changes and you've
given everything you got limiting that
is okay too it's fighting for love it's
fighting for positivity and it's putting
that on a pedestal over any other
attribute people put loyalty above
positivity and love and I love it
because I respect it but if you're loyal
and your loyalty is continuing to drive
you into negativity because you're being
loyal to a negative energy you're not
being loyal you're being an enabler to
bad behavior